de héroe a villano
paul rusesabagina conocido como el héroe
de hotel rwanda fue declarado culpable
de ser parte de un grupo responsable de
ataques terroristas deberá cumplir 25
años de prisión de ataque atacaron a
personas en sus hogares atacaron a
personas en sus autos e incluso en la
carretera cuando viajaba online
a sus 67 años rusesabagina reconoció
pertenecer al movimiento de ruanda por
el cambio democrático pero negó la
responsabilidad de la violencia de su
brazo armado el frente de liberación
nacional señalado de ataques terroristas
en 2018 y 2019 por este motivo se ha
negado a participar en el juicio que ha
calificado de farsa y en el que se juzga
a otras 20 personas
fue detenido en 2020 en dubai algo que
ha sido considerado por su entorno como
un secuestro human rights watch lo
calificó de desaparición forzada
mientras que su hija calificó su
detención de persecución política
este veredicto se basa en un juicio
injusto sobre un hombre torturado al que
han negado todos sus derechos y que ha
sido secuestrado a través de sus
fronteras internacionales internacional
en 2004 una película de hollywood
conocida como hotel rwanda mostró la
labor de rescate que hizo rusesabagina
durante los 100 días de genocidio
youtube en 1994 en el que murieron más
de 800.000 tutsis y hutus moderados unas
1200 personas fueron salvadas al
refugiarse en el hotel male collins
rusesabagina y el actual presidente paul
kagamé de etnia tutsi fue quien detuvo
el genocidio sin embargo desde su toma
de poder rusesabagina principalmente
desde eeuu ha sido un fuerte opositor de
su gobierno denunciando violaciones de
derechos humanos